サッバパパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチッッタパリオダパナン エタング ブッダナ サーサナン
では よろしくお願いします
今日は随分簡単なテーマです
そういうわけで さっさと
分解して理解していきましょう
えーと  そんなもんですね
はい 次に行きます えーと
こちら読めない 未来ですね
これは私は英語で THE FUTURE というね
ただのFUTURE ではなくてね
あの ちょっと意味が違いますね
とにかく未来ですね えーと
未来というのはね まあ先生
まあ未来心配しますね
私たちは誰だってね 未来心配するんだから
まあいろんなことを貯めて貯めていかなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
それで未来を知れないということは
私たちだけの問題ですかね
いえ 全ての生命の問題です
誰にだって未来っていうのは知らないんですね
ですから 誰でも貯めて貯めていかなくちゃいけないんです
この貯め方と貯める量
貯める質 種類などがあなたの未来像によって変わるんです
これは面白いんですよ
我々はいろんなものを貯めていくんですね
これはなんでそれをやっているのかというと
私が未来はこうなるでしょうと
私個人の未来像があるんです
それでそれぞれの人が自分が描いている未来があるんですよ
それに合わせて準備しているんですね
だから人間というのは貯めるものはもういろいろですよ
みんな同じものを貯めることはしませんね
だから まあそこも面白いといえば面白いんですね
ですから 世の中で多数多数の多種類のコレクターたちがいるんですよ
世の中を見るとみんなコレクターなんですよ
だっていろんなものを集めているんですよ
何も持ってない人っていうのはいないんです
そういうことで 人間をね
ちょっと研究して この人はどのどのどんなものを貯めているのかどうかね
そうすると その人が頭で描いている未来像を見えてくる
まあ結局自分でもいいんでしょ
自分が貯めているものってね
自分の未来像をね 見れば
未来を知らないので心配ね
だからいつでもよく心配っていうことあるんですね
本来 未来を知ることは不可能です
これは仏教的に断言しますよ
これ不可能です 仏教は断言するんだけど
世間は絶対認めませんね
何としてでも未来を知りたいんです
だからどんな方法でも受け取ります
毎日30分逆立ちしていれば
ちょうど 3ヶ月間経ったところで
あなたの未来を見るビジョンが現れますと言ったらやらない？やりますよ
未来は知りたいんですよ
逆立ちぐらいは 何のこともね
もっとひどいこと頼んだってもね
やります だからそれぐらい未来を知りたいんですよ
だから世の中にあるこのインチキっていうやつをね
占いとかね ホラスコープとかね
手相 手相 人相 何々とかね
そうそう いろいろあるんですね
我々はどこかでこの頭空にしときたくはないんですね
星占いでもまあ勉強しても悪くないんだと
という気持ちでいるんですね
だから誰にだって興味があってね
未来を知りたいという
だからいろいろ考えるんですね
もしかするとね あの占いには何かあるかもしれませんとかね
しっかり勉強すれば正しく占うことできるかもとかね
いろいろ考えてるんですね
考えて迷信を殺さないで
とにかく生かしてあげるんです
世の中いくら科学が発展しても
この迷信は信ないのは我々生かしてあげてるんだからなんです
超科学者であっても生かしてあげるんですよ
迷信を 人は人間だからね
未来は知らないんですよ
未来の予言をしをしそうな学問っていうのは
ありがたく感じるんですね
一定して流れるものについて
ある程度の推測はできます
だから未来はまるっきり真っ暗ではないんです
科学者も明日雨が降るか降らないかと言ってるでしょうに
それは未来でしょう ですから真っ暗というわけじゃないんです
この明日雨が降るか降らないか
明日暴風雨になるかならないかとかは
どうやって予測するんですか？星占いで？あれは昔中国であったいろいろ
何かの骨なんかで何か書いてガーッと
それで占ってますかね
そういうのはやってないね
最低ダイスでも明日雨でしょうかとね
かけるかけないんですよ
だからそちらはっきり言ってもですよ
この予測は完璧不可能ということではないんですね
だから物事の因果法則
関係を勉強すれば 雲はどんな種類あるのか
空気圧と雲の関係どうなるのかどうかね
で 空気の流れはどうなっているのかどうかね
そういうところをしっかり勉強して勉強して
因果法則か因果関係をある程度でわかると予測できますね
この低気圧でこんな風に雲が溜まってるんだから
おそらくこの時間になると地球の時間回転わかってるんだからね
この時間になると 雷伴う豪雨でしょうと言えますね
ということは それは仏教と
的に考えても この一定の流れ
一定して流れるものについてある程度の推測はできます
しかし 未来に対する予言にはなりません
ああいうのは推測なんですね
結構当たりますけどね
結構天気予報とかね しっかり当たってるし
でも予言ではありませんね
推測です  いい例で考えましょうか
例えば 生まれた赤ちゃんが将来大人になる
すごい予言ですね 全然どうしたことないでしょう
そんなこと私が言ったんだから
皆様いくらでも私を予言者扱いしないでしょ
それは可能性を言ってるだけです
確かではないんです 今日生まれた赤ちゃんが大人になるということは
決して確かじゃない 可能性あります
法則に沿った推測です
だから我々は人間の法則を知っていますよ
毎日毎日どんな程度で変化するのか
どういうふうに年ごとにどんなふうに変化あるのかとか知ってるんですね
だからそれに合わせたら
この赤ちゃんもね あとまあ 20年ぐらい経つと結構立派な大人になりますよと言えるんだけど
それは推測です 予言ではありません
これちゃんと区別しましょう
推測と予言 占いは嘘 で
まあそこで 何を貯めれば良いのかとはっきりわからないので
何でも良いから貯め込んでみるという生き方が現れるんです
それで今日は貯める方法だから
あの未来のために貯めていくんですよ
過去のためにものを置くことしない
しないでしょ これは将来必要でしょうと
いつでも将来ですよ あの考古学の発掘する人々が
このガラクタを見つけたら
ちゃんと綺麗に埃を落として
綿で巻いて 丁寧に箱に入れて持っていくでしょ
貯めてるんですね 古いもの
何のため？これはさらに研究できると
実験室で これはもうこれ学会で発表できるぞと
結局将来のためなんです
こんな難しいことじゃない
もう過去死んじゃったんだからね
過去に対してどうすることもできないんです
何することもできるのは将来ですよ
それでまあ 私はこの人間の生き方中心に喋ってますから
人間というのは将来わからないでしょう
だから将来のために準備して
何を貯めればいいかわからないんだから
とにかく何でもいいんだから貯めて貯めましょうということになっちゃうんです
面倒くさい もう何でもいいんだから貯めましょうと
だからそういう人間 ゴミも貯めるし
箸袋も貯める人々いるんだから
使った木ってだけじゃないんです
ある人は箸袋がある人はこの捨てたこのガラス瓶
貯めるは貯めるはコレクターで
これ日本ですよ いろんなものを貯める
これ なんとか役に立つと思ってるんですよ
とにかくこれは仏教で一般論で見れば
人間っていうのは変な生き物なんですね
いろんなものを持っていってた
何ですか？というわからない
持っていっては置いておく
だってね まあ牛とか豚とかヤギとか
自分のもう家で 家で もう土地で持っていくのはわかりますよ
食べるんだからね 他の動物もね
トカゲやら持っていっては箱に入れて置いておく
時々ヘビを持っていっては
箱に入れて餌をあげて置いておく
もう今日ちょっとニュースで見たんだけど
なんだらかんだらインドネシアのオウムをね
鳥をね もう 80万に売っちゃって逮捕されましたと
許可取ってなかったと
この人貯めるものの切りがないでしょ
だから なんか面白いんですよ
何でもいいんだから貯めておく
はい そういうわけで 私はこの蓄えることっていうのは誰でもやってます
これは勘違いしないでください
私は仏教だからね これはやめてくださいと言ってるわけじゃないんです
どうぞやってください
でもあんた方おかしいやとそれだけ言ってるの
だから あの これはおかしいと言ったっても止められないんですね
だって将来知らないんだから
だからこの貯めることは悪いというふうに結論作ることはできないんです
トラブルがある 世の中はもう何か善悪
悪い良い判断できませんよ
結婚することが悪いですか？とかね
良いことですかと わかりませんよ
結婚したらトラブルが起こる
逆 独身でいればトラブルが起こりますよと
それしか言えないんですよ
だからトラブル起こることからは逃げられません
だから人間やってることはそんなどうでもいいんで
勝手にやれば いろんなものを貯め
貯めて溜め込んで生きたければもういいんですよ
もしゴミでも貯める人がいれば
私のゴミもあげます だって私は使って
もうあまり使いたくないという衣とか結構あるんですけどね
どうすればいいかとよくわからなくて
衣っていうのはなかなかゴミに出せないんです
よく困るんです はい それで我々はこの貯める加える人間を行うことの倫理と道徳
それやったらいいんじゃないんですかね
もう何のことなく ハチャメチャハチャメチャ溜めまくるんじゃなくて
加えまくるんじゃなくて
ちゃんと倫理と道徳を考えて貯めていく
だから まず何を 何のために
どれぐらい期間 という問いを考えなければ
考えるならば良いのではないでしょうかと
これって倫理ですよ 何を？何でもいいという答えではないんですよ
何のために？よくわかりません
だから答えじゃないんですよ
もし皆様 この質問にね
何を？何でもいい 何のため？わかりません
何かに役に立つかも 次の質問
どれぐらい？あればあるほどいい
答え 次の質問 期間？わかりません
できるだけ長く これだったら何の道徳もないんですね
何の倫理もないんです
できればこの質問に答え持ちましょう
未来 未知の未来という現象が引き起こす問題です
何でこういう問題ね 出てくるのかというと
やっぱり未来は知らないんですね
だから我々はこのWhat? Why? How much? How long? というね
これちょっと考えた方がいいんですね
あの明確な答えなくてもいいんです
一応その条件を考えておく
いつでも明確な答えを知ってるわけじゃないんだからね
明確な答え知らなくても
なんとなく答えを知ってほしいんですね
しかし 一般人がこのWhat? Why? How much? How long? ってそういうものを考えちゃうと
精神的におかしくなる可能性もあります
これ可能性じゃないんですよ
ほとんどおかしくなっているんです
世の中 人間というのは常識な人間というのはそれほどいないんです
なぜかというと このこの問題は考えているんだけど
答えが私が出した答えなんですね
あなたは何を貯めるか蓄えますかというと
わかりません だから何でもいいんですという答えをするんです
何でもいいんだと言ったら無限ですからね
何のためかといったら
別に何とか役に立つでしょうと
これってもうちょっと何かしら役に立つ話ではね
何もうまくいかないんですね
だから そうやって脳細胞で把握できないところまで
この未来を知らないという感情をね
持っていくんだから 人間というのはほとんど常識が壊れているんです
だから私はそこを悪口言ってます？じゃないです
世界見てください 世界のことを見ると
なんかみんな常識ないんですね
自分やっていることに必死で
貯めて貯めて貯めて貯めまくっていく
だから皆様の友達いるでしょ？コレクターたちが
皆様方 びっくりしてコレクション見るんだけど
こいつはバカだからと心の中で言わない？お金はいくらでも使えますよとね
こういう品物を買うためには
もっと金を街に使った方がいいやと思いますけど
あいつは好きで好きであれはね
言っても聞いてくれないんだからといって諦めちゃう
だから結局は常識じゃないでしょ
かえって常識な連中は名前売れるコレクターにならないでしょ
常識だったら というわけで
非常識な人間が世の中で国際新聞
雑誌も載れるぐらいのコレクターにもなります
しかし 非常識ですよ どう見ても
何でも貯める あるいは貯めるが使わない
他人と決して共有しない
などの問題も出てきます
これでこの貯める世界っていうのは人間の世界で
誰でも貯めて貯めていく
そちらにはもうやっぱり倫理道徳を入れた方がいいんですよ
私はちょびっとこの倫理道徳ないところ
とにかくこの何でも貯める貯める
無差別に これってやめた方がいいでしょ
だからそれなりに選んだ方がいいんですね
そこで貯めただけで 私たちやっていたことをね
本とかあったら買うんです
買っておいとくんです
だから今も私もそれやってますよ
いろいろ珍しいというか
すごい研究したね 本とか何か見つけると
あ これいい本出来てるんだとかね
高いお金出しても買ってきて
...置いておく この 2週間前で
私はこのマッジマ中部経典の現代英訳バージョンで調べて
あるフレーズを調べたかったんですね
それで あ 中部経典の英訳バージョンの部屋にあった？あったねと思って探すと
3冊あるんですよ 同じ本
これ ビニール袋入ったまんまで
だから見るたびに買ったでしょ
買って置いた この本買ってるんだと忘れて
また本屋さんで見つけてまた買っちゃった
だからバカでしょ？結局は
そうやって結構リピートされている本があるんです
で 買ってすぐ読みならば
その問題は起きません
だから読めないんですよ
参考に使う本だから 用事があったら読むんであって
そういうことで この溜めるが使わないっていうこともね
ありますよ これは本の場合はね
まあそんなに大げさな問題になりませんだけど
いろんなものを溜めて使ってないっていうことあるでしょうね
それから使おうとすると使えないんです
特に最近の品物はそうなんだよ
電子機械って 機械っていうのは今は持てないんです
昔の 例えばね あの 150年前で車買って
そのまま油塗って置いておけば
今でも走れるんです 機械だから
こういう電子機器はそうじゃないんです
空気のあるあれで死んでいくんです
ICチップいっぱい入ってるやつらはね
役に立たん すごい寿命が短い
ということで 使わないで置いといて
後で あ あったっけ あんなのは
と見つけたら使えないっていうこともありますね
何のために苦労して溜めておいたのかとね
それから人間というのは
自分のものは他人と共有しないんですね
触るなよというね 感じになっちゃうんですね
これもすごく危険なんですね
あの 問題が起きます そういうことで
はい それで名詞 これって漢字合ってますか？名詞っていうの
ん？ 自我の名刺ってカードのことですよね
これだと  この貯めることはね
私たちの名刺になってますね
自我の名刺 自我を張るために使っているでしょ
貯めたもので自分のアイデンティティを作る人もいます
人もではなくて ほとんどいますよ
物を貯めて それで私はこういうものだよと言いたいんですね
アホじゃないかなと思いますけど
まあ今日はもう珍しいものをたくさんコレクションしている
素晴らしい 世にも指で数えられるぐらい
なんとか珍しいコレクターがいるんだよって言ったら
みんなアイドールで拍手で
バカじゃないんですか？だからそれその人の自我なんですよ
その人のアイデンティティなんですね
物を貯めて これ大富豪
億万長者 地主 作家うんぬんなど
貯めたもので自分のICを作っているんです IC
っていうのはあのICじゃなくて
あのアイデンティティカードなんですね
番号ですね まあインテグレーテッドチップではないんです
まあとにかく 自分がいろんなものを貯めて
それで自我を作っているんですね
歴史学者といえば 歴史の情報を貯めているんですね
家に行ってみたら歴史ばっかしなんですね
例えば芸術家で彫刻家
彫刻家といっても木彫りの彫刻家と
家に行ったら何を見つかる？もう
まあいろいろ木材ばっかしでね
家ですかと聞きたくなるぐらい
だから貯めることによって自分のアイデンティティを作るんですね
問題起きます 貯めて貯めて
私はこういうものだと名刺まで作っちゃうと
自分の権利がなくなるんです
貯めたものから ちょっと変です
これちょっとあんまり説明したくないんだけどね
自分がこの管理者に変わるんですね
守らなくちゃいけないんです
使用権は失います  億万長者の場合はそれほどないんだけど
長者番付に名前が載っちゃったら
これでアイデンティティを作りたいと思ったら
大胆なお金使えなくなっちゃうんです
新しい会社作ってやるぞとかね
新しい何かにもう金出してやるぞとかね
1兆でもいいんだから
なんとかベンチャーに出してやるぞとかできないんです
そういうことで このこういうこの循環が起こるんですね
貯めること 英語で言えばポゼッションなんですね
それでビルディングで自我を作るんですね
そこでものを持つことで自我を作る
自我を持つことで またさらにものを持つことになる
だから歴史学者という人が
そこまでもうボロボロ老人になって倒れるところまで歴史の知識を貯めて貯めていくんです
もうもうあんたにいらんでしょって言ったっても
学者はやめませんよ 病院に死にそう発作で運ばれたっても
そこででもちょっと論文書いたり
研究資料を読んだりするんです
それは自分の研究分野です
だからどうなっているのかというと
貯めて貯めて貯めすぎちゃって
この貯めたものの管理しなさいと使われているんですね
だから面白いでしょう
だから皆様 金貯めるでしょ
これは自分で偉そうに使いたいでしょ
自分がかっこつけたいでしょ
金あるぞと 私が貯めた金は好きなように使うぞという
ちょっと自由を感じているでしょうね
だからそのために誰だって貯めるんです
だから本買う人も図書館で本を読むとちょっと制限がありまして
いろんな条件読まな飲まなくちゃいけないし
面倒くさい じゃあ自分で買ってやるぞと思ったら
そこを持つことによって自由でしょ
でも持ちすぎちゃうと
こういう変なことになっちゃうんです
個人も本を買いて書いて買いまくっていくと
あらゆる分野の本はもう何万冊でも何百万冊でも溜まっちゃうでしょ
そうすると自分が個人ライブラリー作らなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんだよ
個人何でしたっけ？図書館
そうなってくると自分に立場がないんです
個人図書館は自分で管理できないでしょう
自分が知識人で 本を買いまくる人間で
仕事に行かなくちゃいけない
それで図書館の管理は別な人に
誰かに頼まなくちゃいけない
だから そういうことで
自分ではこの本はこちらに置きましょうということさえもできなくなっちゃうんです
自分が雇っている図書館の管理人が何をやっているのかと
放っておけと言うんです
本は正しく整理整頓しなくちゃいけないんだと
主人に文句言っちゃうんですよ
そういうことだから そういう変な現象が起こるんですよ
溜めまくる人にとっては
だから  10万貯めた人がすごく楽しくなっちゃう
10万もあるぞと なんとかしましょうよとかね
どこかに行きましょうとか
自由を感じる それ 100万になっちゃうと
自由がちょびっと弱くなるんです
自由が強くなったわけじゃないんです
1,000万  1億になってくると
さらに自由がきつくなっていくんです
かなり金持ちになると
自分のお金は会社で管理するんであって
自分には手足は出ません
はい 次に行きましょうか
次は計画的に貯めるというテーマ
計画的に努力して貯めなくてはならないものもものがあります
ありますよ しっかり貯めなさいよ
どういうものかというと
財産 知識 能力 そんなのは降ってくれませんよ
山に入ったらいくらでも拾いますですかね
拾えません 毒キノコぐらいは拾えますけど
だからこういうものを我々は計画を立てて貯めておかなくちゃいけないんです
仏教はさらにことを言うんですね
徳 いわゆる功徳も必ず貯めなさいと仏教は言うんです
財産ぐらい知識ぐらい得なさいっていうのは
仏教でなくてもね 誰だってわかるところ
だからそれに仏教はちょっと一項目使えるんです
加えるんです 功徳を貯めなさいと
これかなりお釈迦様はいろんなところで功徳を加えなさい
蓄えなさい 功徳を貯めなさいとかね
よく言っているんです
貯めるならば何を貯めればいいのかと質問すると
功徳だよというんです
野球選手のカードですよとは言わないんです
子供に聞いたらそういう答えになりますけどね
お釈迦様の答えは 人は何を貯めればいいかと
男性だったら まあ今例えばね
今ドルを変動しても金が
例えば僕わかりませんけど
最近の状況はね もし金が上がって金買った方がいいんじゃない？とかね
あれ 国債国債買った方がいいんじゃない？とかね
それで貯めるものを考えちゃいますけどね
お釈迦様に聞いちゃうと
功徳を貯めなさいというんですね
功徳以外 意図的に貯めるものは勝手に逃げてしまうこともあるので
気づくことも必要 そこで問題
功徳は勝手に逃げません
功徳っていうのは良いことをして
そのエネルギーを自分がいただく
この喜びを それは逃げません
それはもう残るんです
昔々 私はすごいいいことをしましたよと
人を助けたことがあるんだよと
死にかけていた人を助けたことがありますよとかね
こんなの忘れる 忘れません
昔 どこか田舎に行った時は
山歩きで心臓発作で倒れた人がいて
私はさっさと人工呼吸して生き戻ってもらえましたよと
この人の名前を忘れたっても
自分がやった善行為が残るんです
だから善行為 功徳は逃げないんです
他どうですかね いくら頑張って知識を得てもどうなる？私と同じことになる
勉強したものを全部忘れてしまいます
金貯めてもどうなる？知らないうちに減っていくんですね
これで日本ではよく行わない起きないんだけど
一応日本政府は一応法律は決めてるんですよ
例えば日本国民は銀行で金扱ってるんですね
あれ 銀行倒産したら その損害は金入れた人にあげなくちゃいけないんだと
だから金扱った我々は悪い
銀行は金間違って使ってね
我々金扱ってもらう 扱った金で銀行は遊ぶ
遊んで銀行は倒産する
倒産すると私たちは責任持たなくちゃいけない
ですから 2,000万だそうですね
弁償するのはそれ以上のお金はチャラ
取り消し それでいい方法ありますね
銀行口座たくさん作る
とりあえず知ってるんだから
ダメなんです たくさん銀行口座を作っておくと
全部まとめて計算するんです
だから私が思っているのはね
やっぱりこちら苦労して苦労していくらか金を
蓄えておいたっても この政府は自分のものだと思っているんだから
悔しくない？政府のものですね
好き勝手に取ってもよろしいと
あの なかなかあれ あの
やっちゃったらまずいだからやってないだけなんですよ
やりたい やりたい気持ちはあるんですね
金取ってやりたいと だからこのやっちゃうと次の選挙で負けるんだからね
ただそれだけ はい それで私はそんなことを言ったって意味がないんですね
例えば 皆様方はすごい良い服を買う
もう貯める コレクション
いくら良いブランドの服であったってもね
どんどんどんどん逃げていくでしょ
ああいうものは だから色があってもデザインがあっても
時代が変わっていくと使えないということになっちゃう
それからデザインもね
これは使えないとかね
だからしっかり保管しておいても
服はね なんか逃げてるんですね
そういうふうに見てください
世の中を まあ金は何でもあまり大丈夫やと思ってますけどしょ
でも金の場合 損しますよ
例えば金のインゴットはあまり人は置いておかないしね
だいたいアクセサリーとか買ったりするでしょ
金のチェーン買う 結構重いものをね
で 買っても金だからね
やっぱり自分が売る場合は金の重さだけしかもらえないんですね
で 買う場合はすべて払わなくちゃいけない
ネックレス チェーンに作ったフィーから何でもいろんなもの
ですから このそれで言いたいのは
例えば自分がいつでも首にかけたいチェーンを買ったとしましても
やっぱり時代によってチェーンの大きさ
重さ デザイン 形変わっていくんですね
昔からあまり変わらないのはパールだけでしょう
真珠だけでしょう 真珠はもう丸いんだからしょうがないんですね
あれは それでも真珠も流行ってる場合も流行らない場合もありますね
それで流行ってる時はつけて
それから置いておいたら
またそれはそのまま悪くなっている可能性あります
真珠は生き物だから そう持ちません
すごい丁寧に手入れしないと
だから我々は意図的に貯めるものは勝手に逃げる
勝手に逃げる そこを覚えてほしい
金であろうか 知識であろうかね
皆様の健康であるか 健康も結構貯めようとするでしょ？いいご飯
いい なんだらかんだらという食べ物を食べたり
毎日しっかりと運動したり
もうありったけのものを塗ったりしてね
で 私のアパートの前に歩く女性たちが
まあ体を隠して もうもう太陽に当たらないように美しさを保つ
保つためにね だけどなんとなく見てみなさいよ
逃げますよと言いたくなるんですね
あんた頑張っても逃げますよと
そういうわけで 我々は金やらいろんなものを貯めてもいいんですが
これは逃げますよと  はい
これも知っておいた方がいいんです
何のために？ここで世界が複雑になりますから
今日は省略します 何のためかというと
例えば豆腐買ったとしましょう
豆腐買ったら 今日は食べたくない
それはいいんです しかし
賞味期限というものはあるんですね
だから賞味期限があるんだから
その日で その日の豆腐が逃げてるんですよ
そこで賞味期限を過ぎちゃったら
もう逃げてるんですね
私は食べますけど 皆様は食べないんですね
だから逃げるんだということは気をつけて
我々はどんな態度をとってもいいんです
逃げる前に使うか あるいは賞味期限もう 3日しかないんだから
これは冷凍保存しようか
あるいは捨てましょうよ
どちらでもいいんですよ
そこは別に必ず持ちなさいではなくて
適当に判断でいいんだけど
しかし その適当な判断をするために
これってのは これは逃げていくものだと理解しなくちゃいかんですね
そうでないと開けたら悲しくなる
あ チョコレートあった
この間もなんか忘れちゃったんだけど
誕生日ですごいいい高級チョコレートもらいましたよとね
だからあまりにも高級なものだから
私は箱を開けないで置いておいてましたよと
それできれいに箱を開けて
美しい箱でね 開けてみたらカビが生えてたらどうする？あまりにももう 2
3 万 4万もかかるチョコレートでしたのに
口に入れると一個も口に入れることはできなくなっちゃうんです
そうすると あ バカ！なんでバカなことをしちゃったと
なんか自分反省するんですね
別にまあもう腐ったってもいいんじゃないかっていう気持ちはあるかもしれませんだけど
そんなにケチじゃないんで
まあカビですから捨てましょうよと気楽に言うかもしれませんだけど
なんか自分がアホなことをやっちゃったんですね
で その時使えばよかったのにとかね
とにかくこの我々は計画を立てて
プログラムを組んで いろんなものを蓄えていく
その蓄えているものは逃げる法則を持っているんだと理解しなくちゃいけない
次のポイント とても大事です
勝手に溜め込むもの いいでしょう
勝手に溜まっていくんだろう
頑張らなくていいんです
勝手に入ってくるんです
自分の努力しなくても
生きる上で自然に溜め込んでいくものもあります
ゴミ 汚染などは勝手に溜め込むものです
ありがたくないんですね
生きているとどんどんいろんなものが溜まっていくんですね
では 溜まったものはあなたは貯めたか溜まったかなんです
あなたは貯めたならば
まあそれはまあ仕方がない
溜まったものはとても危険です
心に勝手に溜め込むのは
怒り 欲 怒り 悲しみ 嫉妬
後悔などのネガティブ感情です
そこでも仏教ではこの物質の話ばっかりしちゃったんだから
たまたま仏教の話もします
仏教は心の話ですから
心にも溜めるものと溜まるものがあるんです
これで心に溜まるものは
怒り 嫉妬 落ち込み 後悔などなどのあらゆるネガティブ感情なんです
勇気 明るさなどなどは自然にたまらないんです
優しさ 理性などはオートでたまらないんです
欲は？怒りは勝手に溜まっていくんです
自動的に溜まるものは人々に要らないものです
だから私はこの物質世界で繋げたのはそういうわけなんです
皆様方は普通に家に 1週間ぐらい住んでみると
勝手に溜まってるのは何でしたっけ？ゴミでしょ
結構ゴミが溜まるんですよ
弁当買って来たら 弁当の食べる量はほんのちょっと
箱の大きさ ジュース買ってきたら
もうペットボトルでね
ほんのちょっとの液体ですけど
それを飲んじゃったら
大きいペットボトル残っちゃって
結局大量にゴミが溜まっちゃうんだよね
習慣になってくると それで私
覚えておいてください
自動的に溜まるものは本当にいらないものなんです
それで 物質から心に行きましょう
心は勝手に怒り 嫉妬 憎しみ
落ち込み 溜めていくでしょう
とんでもないものない
いらないんです 言い訳しないでください
みんなだって怒りますよ
そんな場合はと 一生懸命言い訳するんです
じゃあ家にゴミを溜まることに言い訳していい？だって人間住んでるんだからゴミが溜まるんだよと
そうすると社会が批判するんですよ
だらしないと 家は家をきれいにしてないんだと
この人は正しくゴミを出してないんだと
それで心もゴミ屋敷にしないでください
はい 次 使い方 えーと まあ結構早く進まないと
溜めた財産などは適切に使わなくてはならない
これ条件なんですよ とにかく使わないものは溜めない方がいいんです
使用期限が切れることも
他人のものになってしまうこともあります
こちらの使用期限と書いたのは
この豆腐の使用期限じゃないんです
もっと幅広い意味の使用期限なんです
号まで入ってます 号にしたってもいろいろ使用期限はあります
だから難しいポイントですけど
簡単に済みましょう 溜めたものは使いましょうと
ですから この使える 期限がありましてね
その間でなんとか使った方がいいんですね
使わなかったら 自分のものは他人のものになっていくんですね
この他人が取ってもいいでしょうかというと
これはちょっと違いますね
この子供が相続するのであります
これ 他人に取られるということは
自分の財産が子供が持っていったということじゃないんです
自分の財産を子供持っていったって別に気にしないんです
自分のライバルのものになるんです
例えば 皆様たくさん金を加えて死んじゃうと政府が持っていくんです
で 家を作ったら家を売らなくじゃなく売らなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
政府に金払うために 残酷ですよ
例えばすごい立派な家を作る
自分のお金で で 作って
まあ間もなく死んじゃったら
子供に家がね 相続するでしょ
で 計算 相続税も何とか税をね
計算したら あなたもう5,000万あるいは 1億円払ってくださいと
ないんですね だから親死んじゃったら逮捕される羽目になっちゃうんですよ
もう だから何のために財産家とそうすると
この家を売らなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
これって決して気持ちよくないんです
家を遺して死んだ人にしても
自分の子供たちがすごく楽しく生活しているならば
それでいいんです これが売られちゃって
これもすごい安いよ 値段で
売った値段 お金は全部政府に払って
子供たちは貧乏なままでというね
まあ貧乏といってもそんな貧乏ではないんだけども
まあ一応お金がないまんまという結果
毎日あることで そんなのは
ですから そんなためにためでいくんですかね
だからいつでも使えることを考えて貯めた方がいいんです
貯めたものをありがたく感じるのは
使っている時です 役に立つ時です
で 例えば何かね 貯めたと言ったっても
これは例えば金だったらね
宝石などのものだったら
人に見せないで隠しておかなくちゃいけないでしょ
あまり面白くないんですね
見せない 隠しておく しかし
例えばすごい金があるんだけど
すごいと我々一般的なレベルですごい金がある
国際レベルではなくてね
と言ったら まあ銀行口座にいくらか数字があるだけでしょう
でも誰にも数字を見せません
ゼロが多いんだからね
だからそれ見ながら楽しいかというと
そうじゃないんですね
その人はそれでも派手な旅行をする
かなりごちそうの料理を食べる
みんなで あの時楽しみ感じるんですね
なんていうか クルーズというクルーザー
クルーザーというんですか
あの豪華な船あるでしょ
世界回っているね それに乗って半年間ぐらい世界回ると
まあ食って寝るだけですけどね
あまり面白くないと思いますけどね
私 狭いところで でもすごい高いんですよ
しかし それでもすごい金を貯めた人がドカーンと金使って
まあクルージングを世界をクルージングをする
楽しいんですね ということは
法則で考えてください
貯めたものは使う時こそ楽しくなるんです
使っていない時はとても危険なんです
使う前に死んじゃったらどうする？誰かに取られたらどうする？国の法律
直ちに変わっちゃって
全部没収されたらどうする？ですから
使う時だけですね はい
使い方にも道徳倫理があった方がいいんですね
仏教は財産の使い方についても語ってますね
だから財産について財産を設けなさいとは言ってますよ
で 使ってくださいとも言っています
使い方も言ってます しかし
これはややこしいんです
使い方 ややこしいんだから簡単な方法があるんですね
慈しみで全ての物事を管理するならば
道徳倫理の問題は解決します
私は怠けちゃってこれ入れたんですよ
経典にちゃんとあるんです
いろいろ管理する方法
あれやこれやとかね あるんだけど
面倒くさい 時代的にもね
適用できないものもあるしね
慈しみでやればどうですかね
例えば 自分の下で仕事をしている人々の面倒見方
ただ給料を払うだけではなくて
仏教ではね 人間としてお元気ですか？気持ちよく仕事をしていますか？子供は元気ですか？とかね
奥さんが機嫌は良いでしょうか？とかね
そこまで調べなくちゃあかんでしょう
あなたの子供たち ちゃんと学校に行ってますか？とかね
だから社長が雇っている人が雇われた側のね
そこまで面倒見ていくと
しっかりした関係ができちゃって
安定して収入が得るわ
財産は逃げなくなっちゃうんですね
幸福を感じる だからそんなものいちいち言っちゃうと面倒くさいんだから
一行にしましょう いつでも慈しみで金使ってください
慈しみで使用人 今使用人はいないんだけど
人を雇うと 雇われた 雇った人のことに慈しみを抱いてください
自分が雇われたならば
雇った人々に対して本当にありがとうございますと慈しみを持ってください
自分が金をもらったら
もう本当にありがたく
ありがたいんだと この金で
この我々家族はみんなね
幸福にしますと これは私個人でのものじゃないんだと
俺だけ食ってやるそうではなく
これでみんなで楽しもう
みんなに幸せをあげましょうという風に慈しみを入れちゃうと
しっかり道徳を守られます
そういう人々の財産は消えません
勝手に溜まる物事の使い方も考えるべきです
次 勝手に溜まるもの ゴミ
ゴミだけじゃなくてね
いろんなもの勝手に溜まる
飲みやら細菌やらね もう結構勝手に溜まりますからね
私の体には勝手にいっぱいの細菌が溜まっちゃってね
すごい臭さが悪くて まあそういう勝手に溜まるものは面倒くさいんです
それで我々は仏教的に見れば
この勝手に溜まるものはやっぱり処分しなくちゃいけないでしょう
ゴミと同じです ゴミ 二酸化炭素などを再利用する
処分するではなくて 方法を開発するべきなんですね
だから この俗世間は何でも無限にあるんだぞというね
すごい考えていたんですよ
だからみんな頭がいいんだから
仏教には何も言えませんよ
仏教はものは無限じゃないんだよと
仏教徒の立場はね 無常だよと
だからゴミは燃やせでは私は大嫌いで
昔からもう そうじゃなくて
使ったらゴミになるんだけど
何かしら別な何かもう一つ使い方
もう一つ使い方 もう一つ使い方を考えなくちゃいけないんです
そうなってくると ゴミではなくなっちゃうんですね
すべてもう回転させるものなんです
正しくものを貯める人間だったら
こうやって破壊することもやめてほしいんです
はい 次 仏教的な精神の溜め込みに行きましょう
自動的に貯める 貯めるのは怒り
嫉妬 落ち込みなどです
リスト短いんですよ もうたくさんあります
自動的に溜まるでしょ
落ち込んだらね 落ち込んでは落ち込む
落ち込む 切りがないでしょ
ストップできない 会社で怒って家に帰ったら家でも怒って
また夜も怒って 夢見ても怒って
次の朝も怒っているんですね
ということで このネガティブ感情はいつでも溜まるんです
だから困るんです 家にいるとゴミは溜まるでしょ
うん 苦労して溜めなくてはならないのは
慈悲喜捨無執着 不貪不瞋不痴
そんなもんですよ 頑張らないと溜まらないんです
金は降ってくれませんね
金が欲しければ仕事をしなくちゃいけない
怒りなら簡単に現れます
同じくここ精神の世界でも
怒りなら簡単に現れる
しかし 優しさというのは自分で頑張って蓄えなくちゃあかんです
もともとはないんです
慈悲喜捨っていう四つでしょ？無執着
施しという言葉がありますよ
愛語ということがありますよ
人に優しい言葉で喋ると
音でできませんよ だから訓練しなくちゃいけないんだ
頭の中で もうどうやって優しい人の役に立つ言葉喋る
あ 勉強しましょうと勉強しなくちゃいけないんです
口を開けたら優しい言葉は出てきませんよ
口を開けたらとんでもない
なんかもう下水道が壊れたような感じで
汚物ばっかり出ますよ
ですから そういうこの覚えておきましょう
この法則を 人間は生まれつき善人ではないんです
生まれつき私は善人だと
ありえないんです だから我々は自然に汚い
怖い精神のゴミを溜まる人間なんです
だからそのゴミを処分して
良い宝物を不貪不瞋痴の宝物を貯めて貯めていかなくちゃいけないんです
だから 溜まるものを貯めるもの
2つ覚えておいてください
溜まるものを貯めるもの
意図的に貯めるものは
人間に幸福と安らぎを与えます
計画的に貯めて貯めていくと
精神の世界 今は金の世界じゃないんです
精神の世界で意図的に貯めて貯めていくと
どんどん幸せになっていく
金の世界も同じことでしょう
俗世間でも能力を貯めていくわ
お金も貯金を増やしていくわとかね
まあもう幸せになりますけど
勝手に溜まる感情を制御しないと必ず不幸に陥る
それで仕事をする時 普通に勝手に怒り
嫉妬 憎しみ 落ち込み 恨みはなどなど
後悔 怠けなどの感情が勝手に現れる
ゴミ 仕事をしているとどんどん怠けが溜まるでしょ
だからね そこはゴミ処分しないと
仕事をやってると まあいやな嫌だ
これはもう早く終わらないのかという気持ちが入っちゃうと
感情が溜まっちゃったんですね
仕事に力がいかなくなっちゃうんですね
はい それでまた使い方に行きます
意図的に育てる精神的な善は人格を変えるので
使い方の問題はありません
皆様方は結婚したら 相手はどのように相手に対応するかを学ばなくちゃいけない
子供が産んでくる 生まれてきたら子供の子育てどうやっていいのかと勉強しなくちゃいけない
仕事で給料をもらったら
この金はどうやって使うのかと勉強しなくちゃいけないんです
研究して知識が得たら
この知識はどうやって使いますか？いつでも使い方を勉強しなくちゃいけないんです
しかし 仏教が教えている
計画的に精神の善を貯めてくださいと言っているでしょ
功徳を貯めてくださいと
功徳を貯めるだけで十分です
使い方はいらん それだけすごい楽なんです
金の使い方を知らないと
大変な危険なことになるんです
しかし 功徳の使い方は皆様も知らないし
知ってる必要もないんです
理由があるんです 善行為する人が
その善行為によって人格が変わっているんですね
人格が変わったんだから
それでいいんです もう
それでうまくいくんです
だから 功徳を貯めれば貯まるほど
自分の人格が良くなって良くなって良くなっていくんです
だから 良い人格の人の生き方は素晴らしいんです
悪の人格を持ってる人がすごい悪行為ばっかり犯しちゃって
警察のお世話になっちゃうんです
だからお釈迦様が貯めてくださいと言った
徳を貯めておくと 人間というのはものすごい自然で流れるように生きていられます
常に善法を使って生きているんです
だから その人が人格が変わったら善法を使ってます
ネガティブ感情は精神のゴミなので処分しなくてはならない
ネガティブ感情というのは心のゴミ
ゴミをちゃんと処分しなくちゃいけない
溜め込む前に処分する人が幸せです
そこで精神だから物質的なゴミじゃないんだからね
我々にはこの溜め込む前に処分することができます
例えば 何か嫌な気持ちが生まれてくる
まだまだちょっと微妙なんですね
さっさとなくすことはできます
ちょっと怠けが生まれてくる
あ これあかん 大きくなる前に消しちゃう
だからゴミの場合とは違いますね
だから怒りがあるいは落ち込みが起きちゃって
1日経って 2日経って 3
日経ってというと まあ病院に行って治療しなくちゃいけないようになっちゃうんです
脳も壊れちゃって もう大変なゴミ溜まっていますね
だから心のゴミがすぐすぐすぐすぐ処分します
仏教はそういう風に言ってます
お釈迦様は 溜めすぎると自己破壊です
この怒り 嫉妬 落ち込み
憎しみ 恨み 傲慢 卑下慢などなどのネガティブ感情
処分しないで放っておいちゃうと必ず自己破壊なんです
人間としてはもう生きていられなくなっちゃうんです
早く死ぬんです もうライセンス取り消されちゃって
人間としてのライセンスは
死んで地獄に落ちちゃうんですよ
悪感情には反対の善感情があります
これ覚えてください 悪感情にいつでもこの反対の善感情があります
それ入れて使います それを発見して
善 悪を善をもって解毒しなくてはならない
勉強してください 毒は毒をもって制すとは愚かな人間の考えです
仏教でそれはないんです
解毒剤を使う 仏教はいつでも解毒剤を使うんです
怒ったら怒ってくださいではないんです
あれは聖書に書いてますけど
殴ったら殴り返せよと
とんでもない話です もう信じられない嘘です
いつでも解毒剤を使うんです
怒ったら相手に怒った相手に優しさ
微笑みをあげるんです
解毒剤 そういうわけで
落ち込みの反対感情がありますよ
傲慢の反対の感情がありますよ
卑下慢の反対の感情がありますよ
嫉妬の反対の感情がありますよ
怒りの反対の感情がありますよ
怒りもいろんな種類がありますからね
それぞれの反対の感情があるんです
しかし すべてに言葉がないんです
ですから 仏教はだいたい否定形で入れて使いましょう
で それは研究して自分で発見しなくちゃいけないんです
この反対の感情を使って解毒するんです
例えば やる気がなくなったと
これネガティブでしょ
そちらの反対の感情があるんです
やる気が引き起こす それですぐ見つけなくちゃあかんです
それで自分で これはあくまでも自分の研究ですよ
なんでやる気がなくなったのかと見たら
あ これこれでこれでやる気がなくなったと
原因見つかる じゃあこちらの反対やりましょうと
例えば会社が同僚のことを悪く思った
で 悪く思ったからやる気がなくなっちゃう
それで同僚のことを悪く思わないで
誰が会社のいる人の他の人を選んで
その人の良いとこを思っちゃうんですね
あの人でいいですね 優しいですねとかね
なんとかなんとか そうするとやる気が生まれてくるんです
だから その場その場でこの解毒剤を発見して
悪感情を処分しなくちゃいけない
怒り 嫉妬 落ち込み 恨みなどのなどなどの感情に慈悲喜捨が解毒剤になります
一般的には慈悲喜捨が解毒剤になりますが
本当に実際具体的に使わないとそれほど効き目がない場合もあります
仏教の戒律も悪い性格を直す力を持っています
あまり勉強できない方々はね
心理学できない 勉強できない方々にとっては
この戒律とかね 単純バージョンになりますよ
私は慈悲の瞑想と五戒とか単純バージョンの紹介しているでしょ
あれは面倒くさくないんです
例えば戒律を守ろうとすると
たった五戒ですよ なんか知らないうちに人格が変わっていくんです
そうするともう上行ってるんですね
仏教の真理を学ぶことで
無知という根本的な核廃棄物の無効化と消すことができます
この我々の感情の源 悪感情の源とは無知なんですね
無知ではちゃめちゃ もう廃棄物みたい
核廃棄物みたいいうこと何もしない
そこでブッダの教えを学んでいくと
この無知がかなりなくなっちゃう
緩和していくんですね
だから無知の恐ろしさが消えていくんです
...たまに良いこともしてみる
曖昧な人々は注意です
でもこういう真剣な人間はOKですよ
でもほとんどの人間が曖昧でしょ？たまに
まあたまにいいことでもしようかという程度でしょ？良い人間になりません
この精神のこの貯める世界
しっかりできないんです
弱すぎ 何としてでも善の力を強くしないと
自分では善を使えなくなります
ですから この曖昧で中途半端ではなく
この強い善を作るんです
強い善を作っちゃうと人格が変わるんです
人格が変わると 曖昧何もなく
しっかり幸福に生きていられます
精神の中に悪感情を溜め込むとは
悪感情は無常なので消えるはずです
感情は悪であれ無常だから消えるはずです
消えますが 新たに新たなコピーを置いて消えるんです
これややこしい 例えば怒ったとします
悪感情でしょ あの怒ったこと消えますよ
ほんのちょっと時間経つと消えます
消えるんだけど コピー一つ残しちゃうんです
これですよ 問題は 感情は消えない
なくならないものという意見に陥ります
だから私たちは言うでしょう
このお前 この憎しみはこんな簡単に消えるものじゃないとかね
うーん これはね 国の名前を言ってわかんだけど
いろいろね 日本に対しても恨み憎しみを持ってる人々がいるしね
なかなかあの悪感情なくならないんですね
あの人々はコピーするんですよ
これ 次の世代も忘れてはいけませんとかね
だから日本人もそうなんですね
他の周りの国々に対して差別感情を作っちゃって
現代若者も親からそれをいただいてコピーしちゃうんですね
それで面白く不幸になるんです
喜んで 自分自身が感情をコピーします
コピーするのは自分ですね
自分自身が感情をコピー機械
感情をコピー機械の停止ボタンを押すならば
大きな問題ではありません
だから あなた方の心にあるこの感情をコピーする
悪感情をコピーする機械の停止ボタンを押してくださいと
それと怒ったらその瞬間だけで終わり
コピーしていない 欲が出てもその瞬間でコピーしていない
コピーするなよと 生きている上で怒ったり落ち込んだりしますよ
いいんです それは コピーしない
はい それがポイントです
コピー機械の連続コピーボタンを押さない
こう考えても 例えば外へ出たら
誰かにひどいことを怒鳴られた
知らない人にちょっと気に障っちゃう
その瞬間で気に障ったのは仕方がないんです
これコピーしないでください
なんであの人がね あんな言葉を言ったんですかね？どこに住んでいる人でしょうかね
警察にでも訴えようかなとかね
そうやってコピーしないでください
コピーすると自分で不幸を作ったことになります
精神の場合は意図的に精神して精進してコピーしたり
新たな善に精進したりしなくてはならない
このネガティブ感情の場合は
コピー機械を停止する
ポジティブ機械の場合はコピーしてください
なんかほんのわずかな良いことでもしたならば
いいことできちゃったねと思ってください
一人で よかったねとかね
そうするともうちょっとやった方がよかったねとかね
じゃあ今度はもうちょっといいことをしますとかね
そういう風に善行為をポジティブエネルギーをコピーするんです
皆様のやり方は間違っています
ネガティブエネルギーばっかりコピーしているんだから
はい 最後に行きます と言ったっても長いんです
けど 溜め込みの超越 まあ財産だけなら何でも溜めて溜めていくんですね
結果は同じ 何を溜め込んでも結果は同じです
悪をため溜めたら極端に不幸になる
わかってますね しかし
かつて悪を犯したことの結果であると理解しないから
また悪循環に嵌められます
例えば 我々は悪を悪の結果を受けると
ああ これは昔勝手で悪いことをしちゃったんだから仕方がないよとは思わないんです
なんで私が不幸になったのかと腹が立つんです
いつでもそういうパターンなんです
だから悪はなくならないんです
悪によって不幸になる
不幸になったらさらに悪を起こす
なんで私はこんな羽目にならなくちゃいかんのと
これはあなたの過去の業やと言ったっても怒るんですね
では善だったら？善を行う人は幸福になりますが
天界以外では自分が過去で善を行ったことに気づきません
良い人間が死んで天界に生まれるでしょう
天界に生まれる 天界に生まれたらわかるんですね
ああ なるほど 人間でこういうことをしたんだから
今天国にいるんだと しかし
良いことをした人は人間に生まれたらどうなるんですか？わかりません
赤ちゃんな時からもうかなり幸福な環境で生きているんです
それで調子に乗るんですよ
調子に乗っていて 善の力が消えたら不幸に陥る
だから 豊かな家庭で生まれる人間が
すべて揃っている家庭で生まれる人間が
やっぱり結局は徳が消えたら不幸になっちゃうんです
しっかり人生管理していないんです
過去を知っていても 天界では新たな善行為は難しい
例えば 天界の神々が過去を知っています
過去で善行為したもんですねとかね
でも今はできません 神々だから
だから知ったっても役に立たない
昔 私は年寄りを助けてあげました
今は天国にいるんだよと
じゃあこれからもいいことしようと言ったらできません
だから過去の善行為は終了するまでいるしかないんです
また輪廻に戻らなくちゃいけない
というわけで 試して溜めて溜めまくっても答えは同じですよ
だから溜める世界良くないんです
乗り越えてみるんです
では 乗り越える方法を説明します
財産は使うとき幸福を感じますね
使うとは財から離れることです
財産使っちゃったでしょ
使った財産はもう自分のものじゃないんですね
自分がそれ捨てちゃったんです
1万円でご飯食べたならば
1万円はもう自分のものではありません
他人のものです 例 ご飯食べなくては幸せを感じません
食べることはご飯を有効的に捨てたことです
ご飯食べるとはご飯を捨てているんです
しかし ゴミ箱に捨てたら有効じゃないんですね
だから食べて捨てるんです
ちょっと捨て方はちょっと違ってるだけ
ですから 捨てることは幸せです
これで理屈 私は無理やり作ったんです
捨てることは幸せです
で 美味しいうなぎ弁当は売ってますけど
食べられませんね 自分持ってる財産を捨てないと
じゃあ買いましょうと
お金に対する執着を捨てないと
それでうなぎ弁当を食べられますね
これでわかるでしょう
捨てた分が幸せになるんです
貯めることはね 貯めることは暗くて何の意味もありません
貯めて貯めて貯めていたっても何にもないんですよ
得るものは 依存と存在欲
まあこれ飛ばしちゃってもいいんだけどね
存在欲があるので 生きるために絶えず努力する
命は儚い組織なので 物事に精神の力に頼ってしまうんです
我々は生きてきた存在欲があります
命はすごい儚いもので
脆いんです だから 金に頼らなくちゃ
家に頼らなくちゃ 服に頼らなくちゃ
薬に頼らなくちゃなんです
頼らなくちゃ死ぬんです
それから精神的な力にも頼らなくちゃいけないんですね
頼って頼って頼りまくるんです
それらのエネルギーも使ったら終わるので
さらに貯めなくちゃいけないんです
ご飯食べたら終わっちゃいますから
またご飯を探さなくちゃいけない
お金使ったらなくなるんだから
またお金を貯めなくちゃいけないという
この終わりない循環があるんですね
理由は 命は脆いものからです
儚いものだからです 儚いものだったら放っておけばいいでしょう
放っておけない存在欲があるんです
風が吹いたっても死ぬ命ですよ
階段転がっちゃっても死ぬ命ですよ
でも存在欲あるんだから頑張っちゃいます
存在欲ある限り苦は終わりません
何かを捨てたら 一時的にでもふさわしい幸福に達します
貯めることの代わりに捨てることを実践してみる
それでお釈迦様が提案する
これ 貯めまくることをちょっと置いて
捨てまくることしましょう
そうすると幸福 幸福 幸福
幸福になるんです 精神のポジティブエネルギーが溜まります
捨てていくと面白いこと
あのポジティブエネルギーは勝手に溜まるんですよ
あの 溜める必要はないんです
溜まるんです 捨てると執着捨てると
全ての善がそこにサッと揃ってくるんです
その力と智慧を使って
存在欲そのものを捨ててしまうんです
そこで善のポジティブエネルギーはもう溜まるは溜まるはいっぱい溜まっている
自分が捨てることしか実行していないんです
捨てることを実行すると
世上のすべてのポジティブエネルギーが揃っている
それと智慧使っちゃって存在欲を捨てるんです
存在欲を捨てることが最大の捨てなんですよ
そうすると最大の幸福になります
これ以上やるべき やるべきことはないんです
捨てたら幸せだったら
最大の捨てることは存在欲です
終わりです いとも簡単に
はい 時間的にはどうですかね
ありがとうございます
えーと あと30分ぐらい時間ありますので
せっかくですので マイクを皆さんに回して質問コーナーにしたいかなと思います
何か質問ある方いらっしゃいましたら挙手していただけますでしょうか
じゃあ今マイク回します
お話ありがとうございました
質問なんですけれども
捨てることは幸せですと
溜めることは暗くなるから意味はないと今おっしゃいましたけども
功徳を貯めることに関しては
これはどういうふうに捉えたらいいですか？功徳を貯めることも暗くて意味はないとなってしまうんでしょうか
功徳っていうのは精神的な能力だからね
暗くならないんですね
そう捉えれば  え？ 暗くならないという捉え方
意味はどうですか？ まあ
例えば電気をつけてつけていくと明るくなるでしょ？消して消していくと暗くなるでしょ
だから功徳ってわかってる？ 功徳はわかる
善行をためることです
善行というのは他人に優しくすること
それから欲を少なくすることでしょ
困っている人を助けるとかどうやって暗くなる？ いや
意味はどうでしょう  え？ 意味はどうです
意味は？意味についてはどうですか？意味
意味は  ちょっと聞き取れない
意味はどうですか？功徳を貯めることの意味は
だから善行為をし続けたんだ
なんて言いますか 続けなさいということでしょうね
これ 暗くなるっていうポイントを教えてほしいんです
暗くならないんですよ
だから貯めることを暗くなると言っただけで
何でもそこは行くわけじゃないんです
だって すごい因果法則に則って語ってますから
理屈じゃないんです あ
もしかするとどこかで引っかかっていると思います
こういうことですね 時々中途半端な人間いるでしょ？私は中途半端嫌と初めから言ったんだからね
中途半端な人間が 例えばね
何かちょっといいことをする
例えば熊本の震災にちょっと 1 日いて助けてあげたり来るね
それいいことですよ それから自慢するわ
自慢するわ もう私はやりましたよとかね
あんた方やったのかい？とかね
ああいうことは暗いんです
なぜならば あの人々は中途半端なんです
たまたまいいことをしただけなんです
善人になってないんです
だから傲慢で自慢 自我張りたくなるんです
それは暗いんですよ その暗さも自我張るところで暗いんであって
自分が行ったボランティア行為が暗いではないんです
俺がやったぞというところが暗いだけです
だから暗くなる場合はいつでも悪行為なんです
あの功徳は暗くならないんです
それは法則です まだ疑問がある？ もう 1個は
はいはい  多分言葉尻で私が言ってしまって申し訳なかったかもしれないけど
功徳が貯めることに意味はないというふうに言われたもんですから
功徳を貯めることには意味がなくなっちゃうのかなと思ったもんですから
それはどうでしょう  これはサイクルでね
例えば人間の世界を見ると
...ものすごい功徳を積んでいる人々いるんですよ
私たちにはかなわない
もう桁違い 功徳積んでいる人いるんですね
ものすごく体力があって
美しくて もう大勢の人々はギャーッと群がって見たくなるとかね
すごい功徳積んでますよ
過去世で でも本人が知らないでしょ？過去ですごい功徳積んだと
その代わりにちょっといい加減に調子に乗っちゃって生活して
もうまた落ちちゃうんですね
それなんですね その その輪廻のこの何といいますか
恐ろしさ 輪廻の輪廻の恐ろしさは
功徳積んだからといって消えません
そういうところで説明したのは
わかりました ありがとうございます
他に何か質問ある方いらっしゃいますでしょうか？ お話ありがとうございました
質問なんですけれども
慢性的に無気力だったり
憂鬱だったり 怠惰な状態になってしまうような状態になった人は
何かが溜まってると思うんですね
そういった状態から素早く脱するためのポイントというか
行為と こういうこと こういうことをやった方がいいよとか
そういったアドバイスがあれば教えていただきたいんですけれども
いかがでしょうか  うーん
アドバイスですね 慢性的という人々はアドバイスしてもやらないんですよ
すごい悲しいんですよ
だから何か暗さが慢性的になったっていうのは
ちょびちょびと暗くなったところで処分しなかったんですね
私でも時々暗くなっちゃいますよ
でも 3分以内でもう消しちゃうんです
3分もかかりません もうすぐ誰かに当たるんです
なんとかして いて ものすごく笑いを取って消しちゃうんですね
そういうことをしなくたっても
もうすぐほかなこと何かやってますから
もう全然持ちません もたないところじゃなくて忘れちゃうんですね
そんなことあったかと
ありましたか それでちょっとそういう落ち込みがあって
処分しない 感じない 下手
それでコピーしちゃう
もっと力強くなる これはもう処分しないでしょ
そういうことを繰り返し繰り返しやっちゃいますから
もう手に負えないところになってくるんですね
この暗い感情が だからあまりにもゴミ屋敷になっちゃって
ゴミの山になって ちょっと地震でゴミが倒れてきて
自分が死ぬかもしれませんと
もうわかっているところに来たんです
すごい遅いでしょう もう
自分がいるのにゴミを持ってきて
溜めるゴミを持ってきて置いておく
持ってきて置いておく
だから家のゴミも捨てて捨てればいいのに
週一回二回はゴミを持って行く
これはたくさんゴミを作ったらどうやって持っていけますかね
リミット超えちゃうんですね
じゃあそんな感じでとりあえず自分のゴミ屋敷を見たら
こんなゴミの山がね 発火したらどうしようとかね
ちょっと地震があったら
これドカーンと倒れちゃいますよと
これ私が死ぬかもしれませんと
今更思っても そういうふうな人間いるんですね
はい そういうことで 私はこの今余計な話をしたのは
このアドバイスなんです
このそうやって このたとえ話でちょっと驚いてほしいんです
このちょっとした感情
ちょっとした暗さ ちょっとした落ち込みをね
放っておかないでくださいと
これゴミ屋敷になるんだと
だから何やってもいいんですよ
この暗い気持ちを破るために
何かやって 自分で解毒剤を発見してほしい
これはお釈迦様にもできません
お釈迦様は老婆に対してアローハというだけで
モハに対してアモーハというんです
だからそれで お釈迦様は言語
言葉っていうのはなかなかね
もうない 完璧にないんだから
私たちにも言語ないんですけど
発見すれば発見します
解毒剤を そういうわけで
なんで自分がこの調子になったのかと
まず見て どうすればこんな気持ちになるのかと
例えば腹が立っている人がいる
いつでも不機嫌でダメですよと
不機嫌でなんで不機嫌になるのかいと
それでそこを調べるとなるほどなるほど
こういう時 こうこうなっちゃうんだからと
はい そこで解毒剤見えているはずなんです
あ こうしちゃえばいいやと
そういうふうな この丁寧な自己観察が必要なんですね
この今日 テーマが軽いんだけど
これ仏教から見れば これものすごい人生そのものを語っているテーマなんです
だからちょびっと難しいのは仕方がないんです
はい そういうことで まあまあ泳げなくてもいいんだから
とにかく何でしたっけ？プールに飛び込め
なんとかなりますよと
それで自分が落ち込んでいる当事者ではなくて
身の回りの人が 例えばそういう人がいたとしますから
どういうことをしてあげるのか
その人のために何でしょうか
まずはお説教は効かないんですね
人間にはお説教する必要はない
アドバイスする必要はないんです
それはやめましょう 人にアドバイスすること
なんとか教えてあげること
で やめて別なことをするんですね
例えば 周りがね なんか落ち込んでいる
言ってちょっと迷惑かける
落ち込んでいる場合じゃないよという言葉なくて
あのね あのね これこれこれなんかやらない？という感じなんです
やりましょうよと それは自分は面白いことでいいんです
向こうはこれでお前面白いんだけど
私は面白い でも面白いだからやれやれよとかね
結局あの人のあの落ち込む状態が消えるんです
そうすると自分がアドバイスしないで
おせっかいもしないで直したことになります
そういう性格で私はいるんだから
私はさんざんみんなに非難されています
この坊主は何も言ってくれませんよと
いくら言われても何も言いませんよ
自分で発見するしかないんだからね
最近もかなり言われましたからね
こういう説法はしますけどね
説法と個人的なおせっかいって違うんだからね
説法っていうのは授業と同じことでね
お互い勉強することでしょうに
だからこれ終わったら
私はもう日常会話でポイントが出たら言うだけでね
それで終わりですよ まあやっぱりこれあまりうまくいかないんですね
例えば自分の親ねをちょっと間違っているところがあって
言ってみてください 絶対聞いてくれないね
...そういうのはね
まあ人間に限る 生命はそういうものなんです
だからなんとなくこの雰囲気を壊すだけですね
ありがとうございます
はい では次 長い時間ありがとうございました
えっとですね あの 日本に来ても長いと思うのですが
スリランカとか他のアジアの国
どこでもいいですけども
海外から見て この日本の社会
日本人がこういう捨てる
捨てない 捨てられない
溜める 溜めてしまうっていうものに関して
特徴というか 日本人だからこそ私たちは特に注意して気をつけた方がいいポイントというのはありますか？ うん
まあ日本人はどちらかというと何でも溜めますけど
アジアの国々から見ればそんなに悪くそれ見てないんですね
だって上手に美しく溜めて溜めて溜めていくんだから
なんとなく見る限りは格好いいんですね
くだらんガラクタゴミなんで
私もいろいろお寺なんか見ているとね
かなり古いものでも整理整頓してあまりも丁寧に溜めているんですね
古い新聞やら記事やら
これテーマごとに分けてね
よくやるなと思いますよ
でもこれは なんとなく批判できなくなってはいるんですね
この溜め方は面白くてね
日本人にはそれあるんですね
もうすごい溜めすぎなんですけど
この溜め方がね すごく真面目にやっているんですね
人生は最悪だらだらだらしないんだけど
物を溜めるとこうすごいしっかり溜めていくんです
番号を書いて ラベルを貼って
大きさ 大きさとかちゃんとしっかりして
何か上の屋根の裏部屋に入れる時でも
ちゃんと出たり入れたりすることはできるようにとかね
えらい丁寧なんですね
でも一生使えないんだけどね
あんなのは そういうふうに理解した方がどうですかね
あれは私も批判しませんよ
とにかく置いておくものはちゃんと後で使えるようにとインデクシングするのは正しいんです
でも一度も使いませんだから
その自分が溜めたものからは幸福は得られない
幸福を得るためには使わなくちゃいけない
その過程で我々は要らんものも溜めちゃいますよ
それはあんまり困らなくてもいいんじゃないと思います
それで地震とかあるでしょ
溜めても持っていかれますからね
大丈夫です だから地震とか津波とかあってね
50年の蓄積は はい 40
30秒でさようなら はい
そこら辺で自然法則ですから
精神的に強くなった方がいいんですね
今日もお伝えそういうことなんですね
物を貯めるんじゃなくて
この精神の方に行ってくださいよと
物はどうしたっても逃げていくんだからね
だからこの丁寧に貯めるのはいいんです
でも使わなきゃ意味がない
貯めたものは 50 年間
家やら町やらね 図書館やらスポーツセンター
病院とかね いろいろ作って作って貯めていくんだけど
地震が起きたら 30 秒ですね
あんな速さで壊れるんだからね
だからそこら辺 そういうことが起きた時で
冷静にそんなもんだなというね
そこで人間の素晴らしさが見えるところなんです
そういうふうに我々はね
何かね 災害に出会っても
人格者であることをね
大事に保つということでいいんじゃないかなと
貯める癖は誰にだってありますね
それはなくなりません
仏教はこの捨てることを訓練させてはいるんです
あまり質問に対して答えはではなかったんですけどね
そこら辺で勘弁してください
ありがとうございます
はい  仏教は体のことを気にするのは良くないということなんですけど
今 予防医学っていうのがあって
何も不調を感じなくても検査をしなさいということで
例えば大腸がん 大腸だと感覚がないから気づいた時には手遅れになるから
検査が大事で 悪くないところを検査したりするんですよね
で お医者さんの言うことをどこまで聞けばいいのか
あとは検査をしたらすごい不安な気持ちになるので
どんな気持ちで聞けば良いのかっていうのをちょっと聞きたくて
なぜかというと 先生たちにも例えばこのデータだと本当に確実にがんなんですかっていうと
研究ではそういうふうに出てるけど
実際は調べてみないとわからないとか
あとその検査のデータも
その前の年に決まった基準値が変わると
同じ値でも異常値になったりすると
だからといって検査をしないでがんと共存した方がいいっていうお医者さんもいるんですけど
それもそれもちょっと怖いなと思って
その それをどういうふうに判断したらいいかということと
あとは検査を受けるときにあたって
どういう気持ちでそれを受けたらいいのかっていうのをお聞きしたいです
はい 質問はまとめたんですけど
この精神だったらね 全く見込みはないんですね
あまりにも愛着で執着で
もうその世界見ているんで
まあ軽く見ればいい もう若い男たちが女たちが研究していろんなガラクタ作ってるんだからね
だからお腹の中にカメラを入れることもできるし
いろんなことで だから調べましょうよとかね
面白いこと言ってるだけで
その通りでいけばいいでしょうね
これはこうじゃなくて
世紀末の話ですからね
持ってくるのは これには答えがないんです
何したっても そう言われるとこういうことになるんだぞとやってくるんですよ
だからまあ検査したらガンやと言ったら困りますよと
ガンでないと言ったっても困りますよとかね
まあ数字がガンの数字が出たっても
医者はまあそれほど気にする必要はないと言ったら
それは困りますよとかね
困るだけに決まってるんだから
もう大いに困るしかないんですね
だからそれはもう私にはもう手に負えない
その精神状態はね 私の答えは
お医者さんたちがいろんな金具作ってるんだったら
まあ使ってみるの別にいいんじゃないんですか？悪くないんです
それに乗る必要はないんでしょうね
世の中別に抱かれて変わるわけじゃないし
じゃあ話しますよ 私は自分の遺伝子を全部調べてもらったんです
なぜかというと 面白いだからだ
そこで相当時間経って
分厚いレポートが来たんです
ちらっと見て置いたんです
これ面白いんですよ 日本での検査だから
いつでも私は面白い これ超面白いで項目ごとに見るんですね
えーと 心筋梗塞の可能性
日本人よりは 8倍 で 脳梗塞の可能性
日本人平均日本人よりは 10倍とか
全て日本人より勝ってるんです
高血圧のもう可能性 平均日本人よりはまあもう 30倍
40倍とか 全部もうグラフもありますよ
だから平均日本人のここあったらここら辺
私はとかね 私にとって
あ ほらほら 日本人に勝っているんだよと
それだけですね そこで日本人と同じ同点になったポイントが一つあるんですよ
それはあの 何といいますか
この胃袋のガンなんですね
それは日本人と同じ値だと
もう笑っちゃいます あれの遺伝子検査で出してるものは一つも私ないんです
本当は でも面白いですよ
あれもう日本人の標準標準とね
比較して あなたは普通日本人
10人に一人ぐらいとかね
あるいはもうあれやこれやとかね
言われると 質問した方のような感じだったら
もうとっくに死んでると思いますよ
びっくりしちゃって もう救急車に運ばれると思います
私はこれ人に あれ個人的なレポートだからね
これ人に見せ見せて どうやって笑いを取るのかと今考え中なんです
まあ突然何か私に言われた
ほらほら 私はこれぐらいやとかね
言って大事にしなさいと
私のことはとかね まあそうやって自分の都合をよくどう使うのかと
まあ一部合ってることもありますけど
この聴覚のところはまた別にお金取られたんですけどね
で 聴覚をチェックしたら
まあ日本人よりはもうかなり 60 すごい倍率が高いんですね
聴覚が悪い方なんですね
標準よりも  それは当たり前なんですね
今はかなりいろんな波長が聞こえなくなっているんで
他はね 私はいくら言われたって
胃袋はがんにならないと思います
他のところはがんになる可能性ありますよ
喉のところもちょっと今も調子が良くないし
またいろいろ調子が良くないところは部品的に知ってます
はい ところで私は遺伝子検査したのは
より健康でいるためにですかね
とにかく病気を早く早く発見して
永久的に死なないでいるためにじゃないんです
ただふざけただけなんです
で ふざけたんだけど ちゃんと医学の能力使ってますよ
お金も結構払いましたからね
で だからそうやってどうやっても死にますからね
昨日じゃなくて前の日ね
佐藤哲郎さんと一緒に
私はすごいもう病気で倒れそうになっちゃってね
もう歯茎が悪くなっちゃって炎症しちゃってね
歩けないんですとか言って
私は行くまでもまた遺言書書いてないんだから
そればっかり知ってるんですね
本気で遺言書を書くならば
どう書けばいいかとかね
病気でお医者さんに行くとかで
なんで皆様の人生楽しまないんですかね
私はこの隣の医者が本当に上手ですかとかね
もっといい医者を探しましょうやとか
そんなどうでもいいんです
隣の方がいいやと なんでやて？簡単に行けるんだから
それだけ でもこれ全国データバンク調べたりして
私ここら辺も膨らんでるでしょ
あれあれもう炎症してます
口が うん 昨日はコブトルじいさんでしたけどね
そんなもんだからね もういつだって人は死ぬ
遺伝子でがんになると言ったって
がんになる場合はならない場合もある
そのテキストであったんだよ
ちゃんと正しくね だからこういう病気にはなりますからね
だから予防にはこういうこういうこととかね
こういうことをやっちゃうと病気になりますよとかね
そういうお説かいもいっぱい書いてありましたけどね
あんまり長過ぎたから読まないんですけどね
で そこで医者が言ってるね
酒飲んではいけないとかね
ジュースとかね 清涼飲料なんだらかんだらとかね
飲み過ぎはいけないとかって
そういうのは私は絶対やってないでしょうに
医者から見れば完璧な食事生活でも病気なんで
それでも だからまあ壊れる時は壊れる
死ぬ時は死ぬ まあ気持ち悪い
こんな話聞くと 永久的に生きたいと思っているならば
どうぞご自由に頑張ってくださいということをしか言わなくちゃいかんですね
だからこの人生楽しみましょうよ
明日でも死ぬかもしれませんだから
だからお医者さんに私はすごい腹が立つ冗談を言いますけど
この歯を見てもらうとお医者さんもなかなか冗談通じる若い人で
初めだからちょっと気をつけてほしいと口を抑えましたけど
何か冗談を言っても仲良く友達になるだけで
で それでいいんです 別に私の歯茎が治す治しても治さなくても
医者もこんなの治さないんだとどんどん悪くなりますよと言ったしね
私もそんな言わなくても分かってるよとね
年取っていくんだからね
うん 一旦細菌が入っちゃうと
これはもう完全に取り消すことはできないしね
だから細菌も生き物だからね
だから明日からね 悪い悪玉細菌も元気でありますようにと慈悲の瞑想しなくちゃいかんですね
慈悲の瞑想はその悪玉細菌たちがさらに元気になっちゃって ２
日 ３日で死ぬかもしれません
私が もうどうしようかと今はもう考え中です
やっぱり悪玉細菌を除いて他の細菌が幸せでありますようにと
どうしますかね やっぱり
困るでしょ 本当に困ってるんです
そういうことで人生を明るく見てください
はい 終わりです  そろそろ時間ですけど
よろしいでしょうか いや
お話ありがとうございました
一つ質問があるのですが
後悔 こちらを消した方がいいと
お聞きしましたけども
例えば自分が自分でにしてしまった行為
例えばただの失敗だとかというのは
まあ確かに簡単に簡単と言わなくても消すのが妥当だなと確かに思うんですけども
他人にしてしまった行為
例えば傷つけてしまって
私自分から離れてしまったとか
取り返しのつかないような行為に対して後悔してしまうことはあるんですけども
そちらはどういうふうに処理したら良いのかなと思いますよ
あの人間に対して過ちを犯したら
素直に謝るんでしょうね
だからもう謝り文化もありますから
素直に謝る気持ちがないんですね
だから日本ではお詫びの文化がありますよ
だから会社が間違い とんでもないことをやっちゃうと
この会社がいるんですよ
お詫びの仕方を教えてあげる
...言葉ちゃんと教えてあげて
お辞儀のやり方を教えてあげて
あの もうなんて言いますか
プレスコンファレンスね
それで偉そうにとか そんなことやってるんだから
我々は本当に謝ることはできないんですね
ではなくて いつだって人にも迷惑をかけたら謝ってください
誰でもいいんです 子供でも相手がね
謝ってください いつでも
それだけ 取り返しのつかない謝りっていうのは人を殺すことだからね
まあそれはやってないでしょうと思いますから
他は全部取り返しがあるんです
その確かに人は殺していませんけども
あの 謝るチャンスというか
謝罪するチャンスを逃してしまった場合とか
確かにそれも謝りの分科がないとお聞きしましたけども
謝るチャンスを逃してしまった場合
その罪を消すまでもなく
どう処理すればいいですか
忘れることしかないでしょうね
チャンスを逃しましたり
勇気もないし 他の方法を考えることもやりたくないしね
結局は謝りたいという気持ちはもうないということを私は感じますからね
質問して なんか私から慰めの言葉ないのかと言ってるだけやと感じますけど
まあ忘れてください とにかく本当に謝ってやるぞと
その方が自分が気持ちしっかりするんだったら
なんとか方法で謝ることですよ
そんなのはもう相手が死んでいるならば謝れませんだから
ね それ以外はね これは取り返しつかない過ちっていうのは人を殺すことですよ
だから誰もそれやってないでしょうね
他全部もう謝る範囲なんです
ただ 謝りたくないという気持ちはあるんですよ
それがとんでもないんですね
チャンス逃げましたと
逃しましたとかね  その時ちょっと緊張しすぎちゃった
言い訳言うわ 言うわ 言うわ
謝る気持ちがあったら
ただ黙っていたっても謝っていることわかるんですよ
時々私は子供を預かっている子供たちがものすごくもう失敗しちゃって
すごいすごい頼んでしまうんですね
もう我々大人に でもその子供
すごいことやっちゃったっていうことをわかってるんですね
でも子供だから どう謝ればいいかわからないし
弁償しましょうと言ったっても
親に金がないしね でもあの体が硬くなっちゃうんですね
あの瞬間で 石になっちゃうんですね
ちっちゃな子供が 私はそれで十分です
こいつは自分がちょびっと失敗したっていうことをよくわかっている
それで私は背中をたたいて
まあまあ それちょっと処分しましょうねとかね
言って 別な方向へ持っていって
なかったことにしてあげるんですね
そこで私はあの子はちゃんと正しく謝ったと思うんですね
だって体が石になっちゃって喋れなくなっちゃって
可愛いんですよ それが筋肉が施してあげて
ちょっと仕事をさせちゃう
もう自分が壊したものは自分でちゃんと処分しなさいと
それやっていると 本人もなんとなくこれも忘れちゃって
また明るさに戻るんですね
だから世の中ではね まあ人を殺したこと以外はね
取り返しはできませんね
とにかく謝りましょうよ
それだけ 謝る 謝るべき相手がもう亡くなっているならば
そこはもう もう関係なくなっちゃうしね
方法があったら謝ります
方法は存在しないんだったら忘れます
しかし 謝ることですごい気持ちは楽になります
謝ることは不可能な場合は
後悔しないで明るくなる
謝りたいんだけど不可能ですよと
そうすると後悔する必要はないんですね
はい そういうポイントはそれしか説明はできないと思います
頑張ってみてください
また勇気を出して謝る気持ちを作ってください
はい ありがとうございます
では まだあるかもしれませんけど
ちょうど時間がきり 10 分ぐらいになってしまいましたので
これで終了したいと思います
じゃあこれ最後の偈を唱えましょう
ドゥッカッパッターチェニン ドゥッカ
バヤン パンターチェニン バヤ
スーカッ パンターチェ ニッスーカ
ホントゥ サッ ビッピ パーニノー
苦しんで悩む生命が苦しみなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますように
はい ありがとうございます
[拍手]